اين تقع ابرز المحطات النوويه الاوكرانيه
تمتلك اوكرانيا 15 مفعلا نوويا سته منها
في محطه زبروجيا في حين يتوزع بعضها في
الجنوب بينكاف
واوديسا وشمال غربي البلاد ابرز هذه
المحطات هي ذا فروجيا التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا وهي اكبر محطه للطاقه نوويه في
اوروبا
وواحده من اكبر عشر محطات في العالم تقع
في مدينه اندهدار الجنوبيه اوكرانيا على
بعد نحو 200 كيلو متر من اقليم دون بس
و300 كيلو متر من روسيا وفيها كما ذكرنا
سته مفعلات نوويه في وسط غربي البلاد تقع
محطه
في النوويه التي تعد جزءا من مشروع جسر
الطاقه بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
تتكون هذه المحطه من وحدتين تشغيليتين لل
النوويه الى جانبي وحدتين قيد الانشاء
هناك ايضا محطه كونستان
تضم ثلاثه مفاعلات في الجنوب بين كيف
اوديسا اما في المنطقه الغربيه فنجد محطه
ريفن النوويه وتضم اربعه مفاعلات نوويه
باجماله طاقه تتجاوز
2800 ميجاوات شمال منطقه نيكولاين توجد
محطه جنوب اوكرانيا وهي المشروع الوحيد في
البلاد الذي يستخدم بشكل مضاعف مرافق
التخزين الماء لتوليد الطاقه النوويه